you
how did I get here well it's a stranger
story than you might think I came from a
world of drifters a place few humans
have ever seen the world of plankton I
came from a batch of a million eggs and
only a few of us survived when I became
a larva I moved among other Drifters my
fellow plankton came in all sizes from
tiny algae and bacteria to animals
longer than a blue whale
I shared my nursery with other embryos
and juveniles from clams and crabs to
sea urchins and enemies we drifting
animals are called zooplankton the most
common animals here are copepods and
krill you could search the world over
but you'd never find a place more
diverse than my childhood home
a teaspoon of seawater can contain more
than a million living creatures it can
be a pretty tough existence though
trillions are born here but only a few
make it to adulthood he may be no larger
than a pinhead
but this crab larvae is an arrow worms
worst nightmare
epic battles between carnivores like
these are just one way to get food but
the real powers of this place come from
phytoplankton single-celled life that
transforms sunlight and carbon dioxide
into edible gold
phytoplankton are the base for the
largest food web in the world during the
night
many animals like me would rise up from
the depths to feed on the Sun powered
feast I was part of the largest daily
migration of life on Earth during the
day I'd return to the darkness where I
joined my bizarre companions cannibals
like this see butterfly mollusk that
eats its next-of-kin
and comb jellies that beat cilia like
rainbow eyelashes
some of these snare their prey with
sticky tentacles while others just take
a bite out of their cousins and
siphonophores that catch prey with toxic
fishing lures but my favorite would have
to be the crustacean fro NEMA it's
monstrous looks inspired the movie
aliens it can catch time bits in its
bristles but prefers larger prey like
saps with two sets of eyes
this female prowls the deeper water prey
in hand she performs one of the
strangest behaviors in the entire Animal
Kingdom
with body parts from her victims
she delicately assembles a barrel like
home feeding her young until they can
drift off and survive on their own best
of all they make the perfect snack for a
small fish like me here among the
plankton the food web is so tangled and
complex even scientists don't know who
eats whom but I do at least now you know
a bit of my story there's so much more
to me than just a tasty meal
Oh